نتابع في موضوعنا داخليا فان هذا الموضوع
الليبي لم يمر دون اثاره خلاف بين القوى
السياسيه فالرئيس الحكومه المكلفه من
البرلمان فتحي بشغا رفض توقيع اي اتفاقات
لها علاقه بالغاز من جانب حكومه دبيبه
وذلك في بيان رسمي ووصف بشغا لاتفاقيه
المجمع توقيعها بالغامضه وبانها تزيد من
حصه الشريك الاجنبي على حساب حصه الشريك
الوطني كما اكد عزمه اللجوء الى القضاء
لابطال هذه الاتفاقيه واليوم اعلن السلامه
لغويل وزير الدوله لشؤون الاقتصاديه
انسحابه من حكومه دبيبه بسبب حاله
الانقسام وعدم تعبير الحكومه عن كل
الليبيين من جهته اعتبر وزير النفط والغاز
بحكومه محمد عون الاتفاقيه تفريقا في ثروه
الدوله الليبيه علما انه غاب عن مراسم
التوقيع
وزاره النفط في حكومه الدبيبه لم تستصر
بالمره توقيع هذه الاتفاقيه من طرف
المؤسسه الوطنيه للنفط لتخرج بيانا مفصلا
بخصوص الموضوع الوزاره تعتبرت ان هذه
الاتفاقيه تمت بطريقه مخالفه تماما
للتشريعات القانونيه كما اعتبرت ان انفراد
مؤسسه النفط بقرار ابرام الاتفاقيات يفتح
المجال للشركاء الاخرين لاتخاذ الاجراءات
مشابهه دون اتباع الاجراءات والتشريعات
المنصوص عليها في القانون الليبي المزيد
مع منير الاشهب
تصدر قانوني حول احقيه المؤسسه الوطنيه
للنفط وحكومه لوحده الوطنيه في توقيع
اتفاقيه النفطيه مع شركه ان الايطاليه
وبعد تصريحات رئيس الحكومه الليبيه
المكلفه من البرلمان فتحي باش اغا حول عدم
شرعيه حكومه الدبيبه واعتراده على زياره
وتوقيه الاتفاقيه هو وزير النفط والغاز
بحكومه بيبه محمد عون يفتح النار على رئيس
حكومته ورئيس المؤسسه الوطنيه
غير قانونيه وان المؤسسه الوطنيه
والتفاهم مع الشركه دون الرجوع الى
الوزاره وهي المخوله بتحديد نسبه الشريك
الاجنبي والمساءله امام الجهات الرقابيه
والتشريعيه